so we're thinking it's an animal and he
said no my name's Robert oh there's a
dude in my room
came home from working to tell somebody
who's in our attitude we found them in
there how do I get up Carlos look
through that door who's up there with
him my boyfriend just pulled him out of
the attic hey I have a firearm all right
well don't use it
it's that door right there
Carlos you staying I'm not going
36 he's on the porch with another
individual I'm gonna be heading up there
[Music]
mind your back
suspect up here uh coming through the
back over here other individual as a
fire Army as it holstered
I'll go put it up just so I can get past
them on
put your hand on your back put your hand
behind your back
put your hand behind your back
Robert Turner man
all right well we're gonna get you out
downstairs okay
36 desk he's got a firearm right here
he's the homeowner he's got a player on
behind me
this individual's got a car he's the
homeowner he's the player on behind me
this individual come downstairs
yeah we'll get you downstairs
he's on the porch behind me this one
right here hey this way downstairs hold
the rest with this guy here
why are we hopping along he's just gonna
hit the Hop just hop dude hop down
you want me to get in front of him
well I think trust is out the window
here bud
five eight
that's my boss
I don't have a seat on here right here
have a seat here I have a seat right
here right here let's go boss
you get a search no I have not
stop just hold still you got anything on
you we need to know about you got any
weapons or anything you got any weapons
up in that attic
do you live on Carpenter it looks
familiar
oh shit did you hurt your leg drop it on
a window or you're jumping out of a
window or jumping across roofs last
night yesterday
I'm more you see my grandmother I know
how I live what's your first name Robert
yeah and your last name is Turner yes
sir what's your middle initial
what's your address where you stay at
where you stay at bro
huh don't cross the way yeah what is
across the way mean
you stay on Carpenter yeah I've seen
them before
this house here
we run around last night on a rooftop no
I came across the thing after you
crawled out of the attic
okay I have to get up in that attic and
check for a weapon
University this would have been the I
think I've seen him before
I don't cause no problem sir I know
thank you hey bro
hey I see why you're doing that
what we got
is it flat nose or cracked what you got
no I do them no personal use I don't
care if it's personal is it fat nose or
crack I don't know I think they anxious
ecstasy now they're using that
that's not ecstasy bro I guess not
maybe well we'll see
yeah I use this it should be in my
system and every day
you got a weapon on you also did you
have a weapon on you
36 to 101
.
36 to 106. I'll take anybody's here that
was here this morning
right here he lives that's the that's
his address with the broken thing broken
windows
[Music]
in the Attic covered in obviously so
we're thinking this might be because
he's says he lives right over there in
that red house along the window you live
at 36 55 homes
okay ambulance is here we'll take you to
hospital okay
you're under arrest though okay 36 this
all right well for starters I mean
you're in somebody's you're in
somebody's Attic So
uh last name Turner Tom Union Robert
Nora Edward Robert first off Robert and
Lincoln well you asked right
yeah
we're just trying to figure out what's
going on is all and let's get your leg
looked at all right sounds like
up here yeah agents and
stuff I mean it might be
right here
we got him down here
for you um might be our individual and
he's hiding in this oh there's attic
okay so go ahead
she's in custody obviously right now for
left leg yeah what's your name Robertson
uh
Okay negative showing an address on
progress
Ive
question from last night
would you say
it was nice I don't know we don't need a
warrant my boy
go ahead
on paper for hit and run involves great
bodily harm hit and run involve injury
and homicide by dangerous weapon can you
feel this
thank you okay
all right sorry bud I'm gonna cut your
whole sock off
it's pretty holy anyway did you both
come home yeah
okay
33. what's your name man 51-33
if you haven't already can you make sure
you get a nice statement from him
thank you did you fall or jump is that
why your your uh your legs hurting
I won't even lie dude that that jump was
wicked though
it well he initially jumped out of a
fourth story window onto a roof
and then from the roof he had to get
down which I'm assuming that's probably
where that sustained because it was a
heck of a jump
they're pretty wicked oh this one here
this is the house right here so from
this left one here this reddish brick
one in the top window
here's the thing dude so in order they
need for any to treat you they gotta
know how far you were falling and stuff
like that okay that's all you're not in
trouble for anything talk to hey
I'm talking to you man ignore them all
right
so they need to know like how far
exactly did you do it from the back of
the front of the house
because obviously the back is thicker
than the front
the back okay yeah did you lay in the
backyard you land between them in the
house
did you land in the back you lay in the
backyard or between these two houses
seems like he jumped from a second this
one here this house here I'm telling you
right now in the backyard
because the front one is about a half a
story Robert
my name's Harry
okay okay we're gonna take care of you
bud okay you hear me we'll get you the
hospital you're safe all right but you
are under arrest okay we cool with that
for what for what for trespassing
possibly burglary probation violations
narcotics sorry bud
you're not going anywhere that's all I'm
telling you right now
good to us we'll be good to you but you
ain't going no more okay you hear me
Robert
sounds fair to me
upstairs uh not yet ma'am yes that would
be greatly get two actually one for
property one for the evidence
is
so just to confirm with him as well boss
man is so the top of this roof here all
the way to the ground level so this one
the white one yep put into the rear
is that the only thing you feel do you
feel any pain in the
up in your neck or anything
I just had to move it away from him
because
obvious reasons yes
all right but I gotta cut your I gotta I
gotta make sure that we can get your
pants up so we can put this splint on
appreciate that yep thank you
we're gonna have to lift them up
Henry ocean William Edwards
he was in a lot of pain getting down the
stairs so
surprised you're able to do that
I think a little bit of adrenaline
probably helped out
King Idaho versus John J ohn yeah
which one you got two of them right we
got two sisters or just one
um
you got two sisters right or just a one
ten four they both reside here
at uh in the upper unit
oh
bye
um
so it looks like the radio break
obviously oh yeah
all right
that's good yep we're gonna have to get
access to his arm we might be able to
get it yeah
who had us running around for
10 hours last night
no but I can get one
bro
yeah
do you want an article dog from the
Sheriff's Office
not yet okay
Robert here copy you want me to roll
with him
got it
uh well no that's how exactly how it
works because you are in custody my
friend but still you should be able to
call somebody not right now nobody okay
not right now he jumped from that
secretary yeah
hi Lauren yeah well we can get on each
side
pressure
there's drugs in that one
so one's his property owns the drugs
are you guys comfortable moving those
cuffs over to
both of them is personal use they're the
same name huh what are you talking about
dude
ah
all right
we're gonna move the Cuffs a little bit
in front of you okay can you lean
forward best you can here
oh I want to do your arm right bro
um
you can't have anything in that way
until we get to the hospital all right
go ahead what's your name
out of place sorry sorry sorry
you don't have to do that I don't know
we definitely have to do that right now
at least
you gotta earn trust all right yeah I
got it I got it
son
51 206.
let's give you a heads up uh they're
taking this gentleman to freighter
foreign
they are taking this gentleman to
freighter
you're gonna just okay
[Applause]
um
yeah if you can follow
you're gonna have to for now
um I'll figure something else so someone
gets in here go so you need one of some
me in there for sure I can't fall on a
squad anytime we have them in cuffs I
got you can move them without you
present all right can we stick with them
for a second before you I
go ahead
would you rather I don't know
yeah I don't care who goes someone needs
to go over them we need someone to stay
with them
happy 51 what are your thoughts